He can't even hide how he's feeling, how weird this is right
now when he's watching unfold. He's like totally put off by it.
Does she not realize how bad this is? Does she not realize what
she's doing at all? >> Didn't he go to war and like literally
lose his eye because of some mujaheden, a brave soldier his eyehole
with their
>> Oh no, Tim left. No, totally disagree. It starts with
condemning the war and condemning Israel and condemning BB and
condemning Trump. >> I would be against Israel, but then
the anti-semites win.
All right, but let's go on to the next Tim Miller video because
he just dropped a new one. All right, same same concept. He's
going to elucidate. He's going to further his same narrative,
his same thoughts. Okay. And the entire country is moving the
other direction. It's we can just be honest. It's moving Hassan's
direction on the question of Israel. And you're like, we're going
to pick a fight with him on that right now when BB and Trump
are careening the world economy. They got us into this war they
don't know how to get out of. They're doing war crimes. shouldn't
bombing schools, girls schools, what are you doing? All of our
energy right now, if you are for liberal democracy, if you're
against Trump, if you think what's going on in this country is
bad right now, all of our energy should be laser focused on undermining
this regime and bringing in more people who are potentially opponents
of the regime and adding them to our numbers. I thought everything
I said was obviously correct, but apparently not because at Sarah
Longwell 25 descents and she's very smart. That's his podcast
co-host, the same woman we listened to the other day. Here's
another 30 minutes on the big tent topic dour. I still think
I'm right. I think I'm still right. Okay. So, the same woman
who is clearly a Zionist from >> Hey everybody, >> wanted
everybody to talk about Israel in the most respectful way possible.
That was the most the highest priority for her was that you would
consider Israelis thoughts and feelings over everything else.
All right, that was how she felt about it before.
So, we'll see. Now, what is her thoughts on Hassan and and Tim
Miller's overall, you know, statements he made on Hassan, including
Hassan and the tent? Let's check it out. Let's check it out.
>> From the bull work here with our publisher, Sarah Longwell.
She has a book coming out. I don't know if you heard about that.
I wanted to talk about an article that our colleague Lauren Egan
wrote with, you know, behind her back a little bit. So, you guys
can alert her to it if you want. Um, it was, it's called, how
big is the Democrat's Big Tent? and it centered around this question
of uh the streamer Hassan [__] who is on the far
left. Is he even a Democrat? I think it's a question. He's one
of DSA. He has a lot of critiques of the Democratic party that
come from the left um part of the coalition. Um his his critiques
of the party are particularly acute when it comes to Israel and
their actions in Gaza and and our broad our broader military
involvement around the world. Um and and the question is there
were some Democrats who are saying that uh Democratic strategists
and commentators who are saying that the the party shouldn't
associate with [__] um because he has some extreme
views. We can you know we debate the extent of this but he said
some things that are either anti-semitic or anti-semitic curious
or adjacent and the questions are whether people should deal
with him. I did I think 20 minutes on this topic last night because
it's complicated and and I just want to kind of break this down.
Sarah saw all of that. Some of that some of it >> I saw
the whole thing. I watch the whole thing. Okay. Sarah watch the
whole thing. Wow. JBL's going to be jealous. Sarah watch the
whole thing. My whole long sermon. And so I just want to set
this up. I just kind of want to break it down. There are a bunch
of sub elements to this, right? Like which is do I agree with
Hassan Piker's politics? Like I do not. And I went through some
of those disagreements. I did a significant amount of throat
clearing about how bad Hassan is. Okay. Yes. As Hassan is bad.
That's a He did a lot of it. He did. It's very funny. Okay.
Listen, he did a lot of throat clearing on how bad Hassan is.
So you can't call him out on that. All right. Don't say he loves
Hassan. So you could come on here. She could be like, "It seems
like you kind of love
I I don't think so actually, but it would be funny. >> Should
people go on Hassan Piker's show? I I think yes, we can talk
about that. Should Democrats campaign with it? Like there are
differing views on that. Should there be a litmus test somewhere
in the party? Like where should the Democrats draw the line in
their big tent? Like should the tent encompass the entire country
or you know should there be polls that people if people fall
outside those they shouldn't fit inside the tent? Those are kind
of, you know, I think sometimes the the conversation like all
that stuff gets jumbled up into one thing and you know, my views
are different on different sort of sub bullets. Um, so I just
kind of wanted to start there. You watch my whole thing on which
one of those elements do you feel like your disagreement is with
me? >> So I think I want to start with kind of Hassan [__]
the guy, the stuff he says and like who is he? Because to to
to evaluate him is then to
>> this is where this is where it's going to go. Okay.
I just I find it very it covers like um or it goes down some
very predictable tracks. It goes down to like basically well
we have to talk about who [__] is and how he lies
about all of his political beliefs and how you can't trust him,
right? How he's ill. How about how he's going to like set up
the MAGA coalition but the the the blue MAGA coalition. Okay.
Cuz he's untrustworthy. He's a liar. He's an anti-semite. You
can't trust him. And so when you say like, "Oh, well, I've seen
some of the clips and they're not that bad." Yeah. That's cuz
he hides his real opinions, right? You immediately disengage
with reality and go into your fantasy and there is no end to
the power of these people's imagination. >> Evaluate the
rest of your questions, right? Is should he be in the tent or
out of the tent is a question of like, okay, who is this guy?
What does he believe? What does he talk about on what is a relatively
popular streaming site? And I'll just give you a flavor of some
of the things that pop up from Hassan's critics uh that I have
seen and that I uh think are quite quite terrible. So, America
deserved 9/11, dude. Uh on China, he says we just go down the
list, eh? We just go down the list. >> Focus on the social
repression or the civil liberties or not even civil liberties
necessarily, but free speech and things like that. But in terms
of good governance, there's a lot we can learn from the way they
perform out there. At least they get results. And he has a lot
of very pro-China uh takes.
>> I Okay, but like is that not explicitly disavowing the
anti-liberal nature of China, the anti-electoral
nature of China? It sounded like he explicitly does his own throat
clear. >> Not even civil liberties necessarily, but he
says we hyperfocus on the social repression or the civil liberties
or not even civil liberties necessarily, but free speech and
things like that. But in terms of
>> Isn't that saying that like obviously those things are
bad? We focus on those things. Those things are bad. But like
at least their government does things I >> Okay, by the
way, Trump literally said that. Trump literally said, "Oh, they
tell you in textbooks that that communism can't work, but then
you see China, it's working amazingly. That's a That's what Trump
is saying. >> There's a lot we can learn from the way they
perform out there. At least they get results. And he has a lot
of very pro-China uh takes. Um
there's one that he says was a little bit taken out of context,
but he says doesn't matter if the
happened on October 7th. That doesn't change the dynamic for
me even this much. So that's the other part of this problem that
many people can't contend with. Like the Palestin Palestinian
resistance is not perfect. They're not like so good. Uh they
have magical bullets. I don't know what that means. He says Hamas
is 1,000 times better than Israel.
like she explicitly cuts out the context there, right?
Explicitly.
So, to me, this is this woman is doing one of two things. Either
she's like a completely lazy like
or she's a totally disingenuous hack. There's no real in between.
There's no good faith way that you say, "I'm going to present
to you who Hassan really is." And you look 0% into any of these
quotes.
Okay? No, that would be if if it's because of some bias, she's
just disingenuous, right? So, like already it started from a
place where I can I can point out exactly where this is disingenuous,
right? With a bunch of these quotes. So, don't come in and say,
"Well, this is who he really is." When you are explicitly cutting
out context to lie about who he is. >> Uh on Hezbollah,
he said, "Overall, what's my favorite flag?" Hezbollah, look
it up. I'm not even kidding. It's actually a dope flag. It's
got an AK on it and a hand holding it up. On Dan Crenaw losing
an eye in Afghanistan. What the [__] is wrong with
this dude? I also dislike Dan Crunchaw, but I would not say this.
Didn't he go to war and like literally lose his eye because of
some mujaheden, a brave soldier his eyehole with their
>> dude. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Does she not realize how bad this is? Does she not realize what
she's doing at all?
Let me tell you, if Hassan were anti-Semitic,
this is his like this is Nirvana. You've let him reach Nirvana.
Okay? you as a
Zionist woman are reading that quote and trying to basically
period test the guy on that quote when it's the funniest quote
and it has nothing to do with any of the actual substance of
what we're talking about here. That's crazy. >> Like Israel
being full of inbredads. You are left
>> Tim laughed. OH NO. TIM LAUGHED. NO. and holding it
up on Dan Crenaw losing an outing. What the >> Dan Crenaw's
eyes being mercilessly by a brave MUJAHEDEN SOLDIER. AND YOU'RE
LAUGHING, TIM. You're laughing. >> Is wrong with this dude?
I also dislike Dan Crunchaw, but I would not say this. Didn't
he go to war and like literally lose his eye because of some
mujaheden, a brave soldier his eyehole with their on Israel being
full of inbredad?
>> She can't even She's trying to deliver it with no effect
at all and she can't even make it not funny. She tried her hardest
to make it not funny. You can't make it not funny. >> You
are left with a country that is packed to the [__]
gills with the most imbred, uneducated, ultra nationalist, rabid,
heredi population. On Russia's annexation of Crimea, annexation
of Crimea was absolutely a justifiable annexation. What do you
call Crimea? I call it part of Russian territory, [__]
I call it cry a river.
>> I I believe he's actually disavowed that one, too, where
he said, "I shouldn't have said the Crimea River thing. That
was insensitive or something." I I've heard him say that. Listen,
that's that's rough. It's clearly it's it's unfortunate for her
that like these are punchlines, right? She's trying to deliver
punchlines
as if they were serious serious like political statements. And
Tim is laughing. >> A Russian River. The annexation of
Crimea was absolutely a justifiable annexation on black people.
>> Pull that up. I've seen it recently where I don't think
he like he's not saying, "Oh, I don't think the Crimea thing
was like true that there were Russian population." He just says
that comment was like probably insensitive. I think is what he
says. >> Black people care about the border. I don't give
a what black people care about. Black people care about this.
Black people care about that. Like, shut the up. That's not how
politics work. And then I don't know if this is my I don't know
how to I'm not going to rank these. But this one's a real doozy.
Date is better if it happens to rich women. If you have these
millionaire billionaire wasp fail sons, at least taking them
out of other colleges so they can only do date to other billionaire
millionaire failed daughters is in some respects, you know, from
a utilitarian perspective, of course, a little bit better. Okay.
[__] told off a listener who condemned the massacre.
Dude, I
What does she think that means? Like I I would just love for
these people who want to go over this stuff, what do they do
they want to argue what any of this stuff means? Because it doesn't
mean he's pro date. He's saying that like, oh, there's these
rich people and he's got the socialist mindset. I can tell you
what he's thinking. He's thinking these rich people oppress us.
They don't even see us as humans. So at least if these people
are going to people, they they're at least other, you know, rich,
you know, transhumanist
evil people, right? He didn't say that. He said something along
those lines. We could pull up the precise quote. He said something
like the the failed daughters, fail sons thing. He said that
quote. I don't know if the she got the quote 100% correct. He
wasn't talking about rich people. He was talking about rich >> On
October 7th, a blood bloodthirsty violent pig dog suck my dick.
Okay, so that's the guy.
That's the guy.
I do not think any Democrat should look to include him in their
coal. >> I mean, he just said Joe Rogan. He just he just
talked about Joe Rogan and the purity testing that prevented
Democrats from engaging with Joe Rogan and how bad that was and
how they all agreed after the election. It was really bad. We
need our Joe Rogan. We can't do that again. And now she's doing
exactly that. So, it's like she didn't watch his segment at all
because he explicitly says the Joe Rogan thing. And now you are
embarrassing yourself again. Um, and and here's the thing. You
you mentioned my book at the top. I just wrote a whole book that
is going to come out in September. It is 300 pages. It's called
How to Eat an Elephant One Voter at a Time. It is 300 pages about
how you build a winning coalition. There's not a single paragraph
that recommends cozying up to people like Hassan [__]
I talk a lot about big tents. I talk a lot about a pro-democracy
coalition. But here's the thing. Hassan [__] doesn't
actually belong in the pro-democracy coalition. He's an illiberal
guy. >> I'm going to say it. Hassan needs to come out and
say that if if it becomes the Democratic party line this election
in the if there are people running on an anti-Israel message,
he'll like shut his stream down. They outlaw ants laws. They
take out all Israel support from the federal budget. Hassan needs
to say at that point I'm done streaming. I will shut my stream
off. I will retire. I will never stream again. It's people make
it about him and it's really not. And if you gave the policy,
if you could just give on the policy, people wouldn't
like they they don't need Hassan there. But unfortunately, Hassan's
one of the people who speaks with authority on the issue, right?
Hassan's one of the people who did lose a bunch of his audience
members because of the things he said following October 7th.
He is somebody who speaks with clarity on the issue. So he has
he has authority. He has like respect there. He didn't he didn't
because there was a there was an attack. He didn't out. He stood
on business and said, "No, no, no. There are terrible things
that are about to happen. If you allow if you if you just allow
for them to emotionally manipulate you, there are terrible things
that will happen, right? And he a lot of people didn't like that.
A lot of people thought he was totally insensitive for that.
And maybe it was insensitive, but it was correct. >> I
He's a China Russia sympathizer who hates women, hates Israel,
like he's all the toxic things. And I think and I was listening
to you last night and I was like I my biggest problem with it
because I agree with you in some places. My biggest problem with
this I felt like you were softelling who this guy is. Like at
one point I think you called it like impure thoughts or something.
>> Well, this is one of my defenses of biker which is also
defense of myself is that if you're streaming 8 hours a day like
I feel like the critics that sometimes like look at the at like
an eightword snippet of something somebody says I'm like you
talk for eight hours a day. I just talked for one hour a day
last night and I rewatched that video and saw impure thoughts
and that's not what I was trying to say. You know I was trying
to you know I was trying to say that you know you just talk for
a long time and >> Yeah. But you don't like you don't accidentally
say America deserve battle. >> No no no. He had some very
bad takes in there too. very very like he has some really for
sure. >> Can I push this Can I push back on this idea though?
They're not takes. Like this guy has a worldview that I think
is anathema to liberal democracy. It's not that we disagree with
his politics. I think his worldview is gross and the way he talks
about people is disgusting. And so like I think he is all of
the things that I think you're you were being too hard on sort
of the third way types who are condemning him because he is condemnable.
And I think it is important. You and I spent a long time when
I was on your podcast trying to
>> take our longtime reflexive pro-Israel stances and kind
of wrestle with that now in this new world. And I'm up
>> for wrestling with that.
And I do, one of the things that is scary about wrestling with
that is that there's a bunch of people on the I'm against this
war. Uh I'm against Israel's involvement in this war who do it
for anti-Semitic reasons. And I think >> dude, it's actually
so it's so annoying. I'm so annoyed by these people. I can't
even begin to explain it to you how annoyed I am by these people
who are just like, listen, I would be against Israel. But then
the anti-semmites win. It's like, dude, I I don't know what to
tell you about that. Like, if that's your position, if that's
how you actually think, I don't know what to say beyond that.
It's insane. think disagregating from those people as you criticize
this war is absolutely essential from
>> I think I think it's way less essential than stopping
the war stopping the genocide stopping the ethnic cleansing in
Lebanon every time you guys hit the brakes AND GO WHOA THAT SOUNDS
a little bit anti-semitic one more child dies and I'm tired of
you going whoa I'm a little uncomfortable with this for more
child death okay be more uncomfortable with the child death than
letting Nick Fuentes or Even god forbid you think Hassan Piker's
the same Hassan [__] then W. Okay, stop prioritizing
your petty online squables and prioritize the kids getting murdered
for two seconds.
Okay,
it's disgusting every time with these people. This is I think
the Yeah, this I think is the crux of the deal because as I said
last night, I argued with Hassan about China on and off stage.
I I argued with China with Asan about his focus on Israel on
stage and I I think that he is a liberal and I think that if
Hassan was running for Congress or president ill and I think
that if he was running for one of those things, I would oppose
him, you know, and I I think that probably I think it's very
unlikely that me and Hassan will will have the same preferred
candidates in the Democratic 2028 um campaign. And if so, if
we do that, candidate window have been very being very adept
at navigating our our very fracture. So, who the hell knows what
the future holds. But like I don't like I I don't like his worldview.
And I think that it is worth objecting to and I think it's worth
people like us objecting to and hashing it out and fighting with
him about it and and arguing about a lot of the things that he
thinks are bad. I also just think that, you know, two things.
One, people that consume him hear that list and like that doesn't
mesh with the guy I know, right? And and I think that if you
came up with my 10 worst takes, it would not sound as bad as
his list or anywhere near as bad. I don't think but especially
if you go back but if you go back to 2004 I have some pretty
bad takes going all the way back. Okay. So I just mean if you
put my list together I think a lot of bull work people would
be like guy like you're being unfair right and because I think
that there are a lot of areas where he is genuine that he cares
about stuff human rights and again I don't watch this dayto day
but I just like hearing this from other people I think they would
say wait a minute you're trying to turn him into like Tucker
or somebody whose whole show is about anti-semitism right now
but like he he talks a lot about making sure people can get >> Dude
it's crazy that Tim gets it. Tim gets like what's going on here
at a fundamental level. It is a little crazy that I didn't expect
him to like really get it at all. He kind of gets it. >> A
living wage and human rights around the world and how we should
care about >> Tucker. So does Tucker. >> Okay, fine.
So anyway, I'm just telling you what people would say about him.
>> Where is Tucker talking about this? What? What do you
mean so does Tucker? Wait, where where's Tucker doing that? >> I
think I I do think that it is is a category difference. A lot
of people who are criticizing me about the stream I start trying
to lump it in with like, I thought you left Trump and I was like,
no, Trump had a lot of noxious Oh, by the way, I don't even think
like Tucker's selection of topics is not what makes him anti-Semitic.
That's not true. It's not the selection of It's not what his
selection of topics >> His views and he ran for president
tripling down on them and being like, "Hey, here are all my worst
views." And like I I I think that we should institute them as
policy. Some of the things you laid out, I think Hassan would
agree with some of those things, if you read the profiles of
him, he's backed off on particularly um he says he says he he
says he does not apologize for any of them. He was just taken
out of context.
That's not true. Literally, the quote from the third way thing
is quite literally he does apologize for the 9/11 comment, but
the rest he feels are taken out of context that like you're literally
just misquing it. And if you're not going to be precise here
at all, why should I take you seriously? You're clearly emotional.
You're clearly too emotional to have a calm conversation on the
topic. So, chill the out and then maybe talk about it. But, but
right now, you're just you're being really over emotional about
this. >> He's like he's like, I I don't take any of them
back. I don't want any of them back. But maybe Okay. Well, maybe
I'd have to listen to that. I guess I >> That's just a
flat out She just flat out lied right there. That That literally
is a flatout lie. It's a flatout lie. An emotional and embarrassing
flatout lie. >> Yes. I just would say that holistically
is it is a category difference for me that from from what you
hear from mega. All of that aside though, because
you know, we can all we can take the measure of the man and you
can decide that he's a wholly unacceptable man and I gonna say
that he's a man that has some bad views and and we can we can
hash that out. The strategic question, the analytical question,
right? Yeah. Is how Democrats should handle somebody like that.
Yeah. So, all of that is immediately
like not really relevant to the question. His point was a strategic
one that going after Hassan on Israel and trying to make him
seem anti-Semitic is a really bad strategy at this precise point
in time that the country is moving in Hassan's direction which
is you know if you start including the rightwing that's unquestionable
the rightwing is moving way more harshly in that direction than
Hassan is and I think there probably could be I I can't guarantee
it certainly I wouldn't have agreed before this election okay
sorry before um before this war but with this war and the the
cataclysm that's coming for the global economy that has not gotten
here yet. It's not even close to gotten here yet. Okay, there
is a cataclysm. It is going to get significantly worse and stay
worse no matter what anybody institutes as a solution for a long
period of time.
It's going to get worse in terms of where the country moves on
Israel. A lot worse.
and and you disagreeing with Tim with his obviously correct analysis,
the thing that people need to hear, the the tough medicine, the
tough to swallow medicine he's giving you is if you're going
to go after Hassan, go after him on on China or something, don't
go after him on Israel cuz you look insane. >> And like
this is where I'm the harshest on on the view that he should
be checked out. And I I'm particularly harsh and I said this
last night and this relates to your point about Israel about
like picking this fight with him right now like in at this moment
today, April 3rd of 2026, because right now we are embroiled
in a catastrophic war that is that the secretary of state said
we did because Israel got us into it. So like you can call that
a conspiracy theory or whatever, but like the secretary of state
said it and Trump has the president has basically said it even
though he does word salad a bunch of times. And I just think
that any fair analyst could look at it and say well obviously
like this war is more in Israel's acute interest than ours. Like
that's just that's just a statement of fact, right? So like we
are in this war with our partner Israel right now on the heels
of their behavior in Gaza, whatever however you want to describe
that, whether it's genocide or ethnic cleansing or war crimes
or just just more killing than was necessary anywhere on he's
he's trying so hard not to actually say Israel's bad. It's so
funny. He's just trying so hard. No matter where you stand on
the issue of children, you know, bad, good,
strange that you'd stand in >> that continuum like this
comes after that. Now we've partnered with them for a war in
Iran that is going to create massive damage globally to people's
lives. Like people are going to be materially harmed by this
war. They already are. And there are a lot of people out there
in this country right now who are really mad about that. And
and they're about to get really mad in the ne in the coming months.
And I think a lot of them look at the they blame Trump, but they
also look at the Democratic party and be like You guys have been
on this too. Joe Biden was in there when when Israel was doing
the Gaza thing. The Democrats have been, you know, part of this
bipartisan establishment that got us into these stupid wars forever.
And they look around for people and who do they see out there
saying no, we should >> That's what you said. Tim stole
your talking points. Yeah. Well, I actually don't even know.
I I maybe Are you hearing something that he said that I was reiterating?
or and I think a lot of them look at the they blame Trump and
they also look at the Democratic party and be like,
>> no, no, no, no, no, no. This was I was so I believe
that and I do say that, but I also think that Tim was making
this point regardless. He was this is a point he was making.
>> You guys have been on this too. Joe Biden was in there
when when Israel was doing the Gaza thing. The Democrats have
been, you know, part of this bipartisan establishment that got
us into these stupid wars forever." And they look around for
people and who do they see out there saying, "No, we shouldn't.
We should not do these wars. They're stupid. They're wrong."
They see people. >> Dude, it's so funny that like if you
wanted people to go to an anti-
if you really wanted people to go to an anti-Israel figure, why
are you trying to get them not to go to Hassan when like Nick
Fuentes is right there? Why are you trying to make it about Hassan
instead of Nick Fuentes? Why? Like you're you're literally trying
to you're putting a big a big like uh sign in front of Hassan.
No, no, no, don't go to this guy. And then Tucker, Candace, all
these people are sitting there just scooping those people up.
Little weird. Little weird. >> And and so in this moment
where people are very bad, a lot of voters that when you say
how to eat an elephant one at a time, a lot of voters Democrats
are going to need who whether they be young voters or men who
don't want to go to war or people whose costs are going to go
up. Like right now at this moment, a lot of them are assessing
the landscape and they're saying like Trump betrayed me. Like
I thought I was I thought I was on board with the no wars candidate.
Okay. And they're and and they're getable right now. I as as
ripe as they have ever been to be gotten by the Democratic party.
And in this moment, the Democratic Party and their leaders should
be focused in my view on being as clear and loud and passionate
as possible. No stupid wars. I will not get you involved in this.
This is this is a mistake. to to the extent that Israel is involved
are the fact that our relationship is closely tied to them is
a mistake and if we ever get back in power, we will not betray
you. We hear you. We see this. And instead, you hear a lot of
Democratic leaders being like, well, this is we should kick this
guy out that's known that's what he's known for. Like if he's
known for anything, it's being >> It's almost like those
people don't really care about you or American issues. It's almost
like those people instead of hearing your pain and seeing it
and being like, I understand and I respect this, they're like,
you
sound a little anti-semitic there, man. what's going on? >> It's
like, why? We're picking this fight with him now. And I'm just
like, I I could think of a thousand other things I would rather
Democrats pick fights about now. Like, why him right now? >> Because
he's making their life harder. It is m people like Hassan are
hold on. People like Hassan are making Democrats who want to
take a stand against this war, right? And who want to take probably
take a stand against the way >> they want to take a stand
against this war. But if they take a stand against this war,
then the anti-semite wins. Then if if they take a stand against
this war now, the anti-semite wins. And that's the worst thing
that could possibly happen. Dead children. No. Have you thought
about it? Dead children are nothing compared to an anti-semite
getting to hold a W. An anti-semite streamer would might get
to hold a W if we admit that, you know, Israel's bad.
And that's the real tragedy that Trump is just sort of like,
you know, doing whatever BB tells him. They're trying to figure
out how to do it in a way where they don't imperil the safety
of people in this country. They're trying to do it in a way that
is they don't want to be anti-semitic and I'll tell you why Hassan
is so d
>> No.
Uh and trust me I I understand that a lot of people feel this
way. This is a genuine thought very often from people who are
lifelong Zionists or have like some stake in in Israel, right?
Could be could be that they've you know liked Israel from for
a long time because they learned about it in history class. Could
be anything any reason they have a stake in the country. Okay.
It's there's a lot of people like this who have been consistently
more concerned about anti-semitism than any of the war crimes
that have happened. And that's really concerning and really upsetting
to a lot of people. If you are more concerned about anti-semitism
than actual war crimes, than than kids dying, than people starving
to death, if you if this is your priority list, then you look
monstrous. That has nothing to do with Hassan except that he
points it out. Okay? And for a long time, he said, "Well, he's
anti-Semitic. There's no reason to believe any of this." A lot
of politicians said this, right? That's an anti-semitic way to
look at it. There's no way there's no reason you should believe
this. But there is a reason you should believe it because we've
watched the exact thing Hassan complains about unfold, right?
That Israel doesn't really care about they they don't really
do like a passionate analysis. They don't sorry a compassionate
analysis for like collateral damage. There's really none of this
is happening. They did want to ethnically cleanse Gaza from the
very beginning, right? And it's like I I'm sorry, but if you
think the possibility that the possibility that Hassan might
utter something that possibly could lead to increased anti-semitism
that possibly could lead to increased violence in America, if
that is what you put at a way higher priority than
hundreds and thousands of women and children dying,
I'm sorry, you're not somebody who should even be speaking about
politics.
You're not.
Get out. dangerous is that what it does is it's exactly what
Trump does. It's exactly what Nick Fuentes does and Tucker does.
It takes maybe legitimate rage about something and then it gives
them an enemy to put it on. It gives them a an an outgroup to
blame for it. And I think you have to be so careful with that
so that you're not doing that which starts with condemning the
people who hold the same position as you for reasons that are
bad for reason. >> Here's where I disagree. Totally disagree.
Totally disagree. It starts with condemning the war and condemning
Israel and man this
maybe Jeb Bush
man maybe this maybe I could give it up to this guy now that
like actually the fact that you ran Jeb Bush's campaign maybe
I don't think that's like totally disqualifying
RIGHT YES THAT IS WHERE IT STARTS YOU START WITH ACTUALLY just
unequivocally condemning the war you don't go hey you guys are
going to not blame Israel anymore if I do this once right you're
going to like cool it on Israel it doesn't mean that it means
unequivocally go It's actually horrible that these kids are dying.
It's actually horrible. And Israel needs to stop being funded
until it stops. Once they stop and have shown they're going to
stop and they're not going to keep going in the direction they're
going, then funding can resume. Then QME can resume. Okay? Until
then, no. Until then, nothing. And condemning BB and condemning
Trump and being passionate and clear about it because then what
happens then if you have the credibility then with the >> So
hold on. He
unfortunately I was very excited and then I listened to the list
and this is a variation of one man bad which is not the case
and doesn't get you and that's the thing is you you have to speak
with clarity on this stuff because unfortunately the one man
bad thing is not enough. Okay, which he just did. Who are we
blaming? Well, the war and BB and Trump. Nope. Nope. the MAGA
coalition, the Israeli like centerright and right-wing political
apparatus, okay? Which is by far the majority popular in Israel,
MAGA less popular in America, okay? But you have to say what
these things are because realistically if if BB wasn't there,
this is the exact course they'd be on anyway. Okay? So to blame
BB for it does nothing to solve the problem. Anyway, we keep
going for reasons that are bad for reason. Here's where I disagree.
Totally disagree. Totally disagree. It starts with condemning
the war and condemning Israel and condemning BB and condemning
Trump and being passionate and clear about it because then what
happens then if you have the credibility then with the voters
who who were anti-war voters who were unhappy about the way that
they see the bipartisan establishment they thought Trump was
going to be their their savior from this that there was this
some blob in DC and no matter which party is in charge we all
get into stupid wars they thought Trump was their way out of
this and now they're like Trump's doing the same that all the
other ones did that that we said we didn't want it he's doing
it worse and so now if the Democrats go to those people and and
go on those shows like they should be on those shows. Democrats
should be begging Joe Rogan or Theo or whoever to have them on
right now. They should be on manosphere shows being like, "I
told you this was stupid. I didn't want to do this. This war
is dumb. Our relationship with Israel is too tight. We should
be re-evaluating it. We should not be let getting dogwalked into
this war. By the way, NBS also sucks." Right? Like you can do
that in a way that's not anti-semitic because it's what has happened.
Like it's happened. And so if they did that and then in 5 months
they're like, "You know what? Okay."
>> Have you thought about how doing that lets the anti-semmites
win? That literally just lets the anti-semites win. Tim, stopping
the war, possibly preventing more and more families from being
ethnically cleansed from southern Lebanon, possibly preventing
them getting a foothold in remaining in southern Lebanon. It
may depend on us calling this out in this moment. But
also, it may lead to a slight increase in anti-semitism, which
could lead to a possible increase in violence against in America
in the future. And that isn't that worse than all of those people
having their entire capacity to be happy in this world destroyed
that their their families are getting killed, their houses are
getting blown up, their infrastructure is being destroyed, they
will never be able to economically recover. Isn't that like doesn't
that pale in comparison to the idea that somebody might get like
a drink thrown at them at some point in the next 20 years? probably
not even because we're very clear about how this is not an ethnic
thing and American broadly don't support this anyway but like
somebody might get a drink thrown at them and like that that
could be
>> there look I it's wild it's just wild to >> at
this though like we you we you guys we cannot you know be shoulder-to-shoulder
with somebody as this view or that view or we have to like then
you have the credibility >> why does it why is there a
fivemon gap why can't it be in the same breath I think it should
because I here's the I do agree with you that nature rapport
is a vacuum right like part of what is happening is that there
is a desperate
Why can't it be at the same time? Why can't you say that Israel
is our strongest ally and the most moral army in the world, but
I do think this war was a bit too much. Why? Why doesn't that
statement work?
Well, well, it turns out that's what everybody's been saying
for a long time now and it's done literally nothing. Got to speak
a little stronger apparently or else nothing gets >> Anger
over this war uh from a lot of people that feel betrayed by Donald
Trump that don't want any more foreign wars in the Middle East.
And like we're almost it's not it's not about Israel. Like for
some there's a there's a for some people it is about Israel.
For some people it is about anti-semitism. Those are different.
And then there's just a lot I think the vast majority of people
are just mad we're doing this again. And so like Democrats should
be condemning it. They should be outspoken. They should be the
one to try to gain a
people who said that if Donald Trump wins again, Israel is going
to get their war with Iran. The people who said that were basing
it on geopolitical analysis. That was pretty hard to disagree
with.
The idea that BB is pushing America towards this as much as he
possibly could ever every time Trump's in office and even when
Biden's in office, that is
I just I don't understand why she's most people are just mad
that this is happening again. Well, this the thing you're calling
this that didn't that's not quite, you know,
did not just fall out of a coconut tree. Okay. This exists in
the context of everything that came before it. Okay, to quote
a very wise woman. All right, this
is not a coconut. It did not fall out of a coconut tree. Okay,
and so we actually need to know what caused this and we need
to talk about this, right?
My god. But people don't want to talk about this. They want to
just go, well, war is bad. War is really bad. When war comes
out of nowhere, war is really bad. It didn't come out of nowhere.
following by talking about this. But I think in doing so, they
should separate themselves from people like Hassan. I don't think
you have to wrap your arms around him. I don't think, you know,
>> he has credibility and they don't on this, though. >> So,
they should go get credibility themselves. They don't need to
borrow it from him. >> I'm not telling I'm not saying they
should borrow. I never said I again, here's a disagreement. I
never said I think Democrats should campaign with him. I I disagree
with that. I I think >> I think they should go on a show.
>> I think you don't think they should go on his show.
>> Hassan's No. >> Oh my god. That we could not agree
disagree more. Oh my god. The people that watch show are not
terrible. the the the regular people. A lot of people watch this
video, watch a Sean Son show. I hear I saw them on the street.
The idea this is this is like the same [__] we just
did with Joe Rogan. It's like Democrat one. Joe Joe Rogan has
terrible views. They have to speak to those people. Those are
the people that they HAVE TO >> THIS LADY'S MELTING DOWN.
She just took a deep breath. SHE'S LIKE MELTING DOWN. >> Oh
my god. >> Joe Rogan has terrible [__] views.
They have to speak to those people. Those are the people that
dude. Yeah. She's about to get a paper bag, man. What the [__]
they have to speak to. Why wouldn't they do that right now? Especially
right now when they're the most getable, >> let's say.
So, so Nick Fentes is out there saying we should vote for >> So
Nick Fentes. Okay. All right. >> Trump is doing this real.
You think Democrats should go on Fuentes's show? >> I don't.
>> Well, Nick, hold on. Hold on, hold on, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. When they're the most go again, >> let's say.
So, so Nick Fuentes is out there saying we should vote for Democrats
because Trump is doing this for Israel. You think Dem Democrats
should go on Nick Fuentes's show? >> Yeah. Yeah, Nick Fentes
is the only one who's saying something like that. Nick Fentes
is the only person who's saying that Trump did this for Israel
for sure. It's only Nick Fentes and his close confidant Marco
Rubio, the Secretary of States, the Secretary of State of the
United States of America.
Like, that's what she's implying there, that it's only anti-semites
who would say that Trump did this for Israel. That is not true.
That is not the case. Okay,
come on. It's insane.
It's totally insane that she is pretending right now that actually
the only people who say that Nick Fuentes, Tucker Carlson. Wrong,
wrong, wrong, wrong. >> I don't Well, Nick Fentes is full
of is the thing. I mean, a like I don't think they should go
on a show, but not really so much because he's an anti-semite.
I don't think they should go on a show because he's like a he's
a troll. He's just a troll. Hassan really believes what he believes.
Like you can say his beliefs are bad or wrong or shameful or
should be condemned and you could go on a show and fight him
about it, but like Hassan is not out there doing like oh you
know jokes about ovens
and you know the the Jew there might not have been that many
people killed in the Holocaust doing trolling.
>> Oh, hold on. Harsh
harsh differentiation between Fuentes and Assad. That's good.
That's a good start. I do like that. I do like when I do like
when you do the harsh differentiation, you say it's like not
the same thing. They're clearly not the same thing. That's a
good thing right >> Like what does even believe? Does anybody
even know? Does he even know? I don't think he even knows what
he believes anymore. Like he's just full of [__]
Like it's it's like a
>> I I don't like agree with this analysis, but I it's
honestly like totally
uh it's totally orthogonal. conversation does not does not cross
does not cross over with what we're actually talking about right
now.
>> Hassan like has passionate left-wing views and and they
should be grappled with I think >> who says that 9/11 was
America's fault and that like I don't think this is a serious
person. This is my part of my problem now and I'm going to both
state a problem and then I think one of the ways in which strategically
this is bad. Nick Fuentes and Hassan [__] are both
being elevated in the discourse because people are there's a
Strizzand effect happening. This I do write about in the book.
The Stryand effect that makes these people more powerful that
>> gives these people a bigger
>> as by the way you seed all possible credibility on the
issue when you pretend Hassan and Nick Fuentes are comparable
in any way. You see entirely
every iota of credibility you could have possibly had when you
try to pretend these two are the same. You look stupid. You look
actually moronic. Okay, that's that's like the only possible
way to look at it. Anybody who does that, they've immediately
seated all credibility on the issue. They can't even talk about
it. They are way too they have some other agenda that does not
include anything that you care about. Okay. platform
where whether it is the earnestness of Hassan or the um the nihilism
of
uh of Fentes, right? Uh people are like kind of there for that
experience and they they it raises their curiosity. This happened
with Andrew Tate. Like there is just a series of people where
the outrage against them is making them more powerful. That being
>> understanding that dynamic
doesn't mean that like there's just sort of a right is still
right and wrong is still wrong. Like I do think Hassan, but like
I felt this way about Madani. >> No, it's on my show. Does
that just make you uncomfortable? Like the phrase globalized
from the river to the sea? >> To me, ultimately what I
hear in so many is a desperate desire for equality and equal
rights in
in standing up for Palestinian human rights. And I think what's
difficult
is that the very word is has been used by the Holocaust Museum
when translating the Warsaw Ghetto uprising into Arabic because
it's a word that means struggle. >> And as
a
Muslim man who grew up post 911, I'm I'm all too familiar in
the way in which Arabic words can be twisted, can be distorted,
can be used to justify any kind of meaning. And I think that's
that's where it leaves me with a sense that what we need to do
is is focus on keeping New Yorkers safe. And
question of the permissibility of language is something that
I that I haven't I haven't ventured into. >> It's like
I feel like the phrase global wise is not something people should
use because even if you don't intend it to be that way. >> Sorry,
just an interesting conversation. I didn't feel like I needed
to step in or do any analysis there. It's interesting. heard
by people as like kill us everywhere and so that should be condemned.
And then I asked him if he had condemn anyone on the show. >> But
like I just I think keeping I think trying not to elevate these
people in the discourse or >> uh reminder that this woman
said she would vote for Ted Cruz over Mumani. Well, I think it's
pretty clear that she is a Zionist, right? That she believes
Israel should be protected, that Israel like it's it's very clear
to me that she's like an obvious Zionist. like she's defending
Israel like outright um
She's like super reactionarily like without without even really
getting centered in the conversation. She is immediately in a
defensive position for Israel and concerned about anti-semitism
over anything else that's happening. >> Us being clear
that they are malign actors like we can have to we can wrestle
with what they say. And actually, I want to say something. >> You
could say this. Anyone choosing their vote on a single foreign
policy point needs to this is this is just wrong.
What if what if your candidate is running on like I'm going to
nuke like I'm going to nuke Europe. I'm going to spend our entire
nuclear arsenal in Europe, right?
Like obviously you don't believe what you just said because I
can come up with a situation where you would say, "Oh, actually
that geopolitical policy that actually I totally disagree with
that, right?" Well, you could say, "So I'm telling you the principle
isn't there." Maximus. Oh, Maximus is arguing right now. He's
interrupting the segment, which is fine. So, okay, we back from
there. What if you are doing something that is incredibly expensive
to the American people because of this policy?
This unconditional support for Israel is what led to this Iran
war is what's melting down the global economy. How are you going
to tell me if you pick your if you decide your vote based on
that, you're insane. That seems totally wrong to me. I don't
see any reason you could make that argument. That seems totally
How do you justify that? Like I obviously this is a problem and
that's even if so I don't even disavow people who want to vote
on we're funding like war crimes against another country. We're
war crime we're we're we're literally funding something that
is leading to mass displacement and death across the Middle East.
I don't want my taxes to go to that. I think that's fine. I think
it's fine to say that's a moral issue you want to stand on. I
don't think there's anything wrong with that because honestly
if that's if that is your most important issue then
like I don't know what else to do what else to talk about. I
don't know I don't know what else to do man. Seems pretty >> thing
cuz I'm not sure if we've talked about this before. I was also
on a panel with him and I didn't know who he was going into it.
This is like actually the embarrassing part of this is that I
didn't I don't like really know um I don't like follow who the
Twitch streamers are. Um and I hadn't really heard of him. Um
or if I had I hadn't bothered to figure out who he was. And when
he started talking like >> like just to be clear, I want
you guys when you when you say that if you want to have a genuine
conversation about how okay it is to pick your vote based on
some foreign policy. Then explain what the foreign policy is
and why people don't want to vote for it. Cuz you you're you're
saying that it's insane to decide you don't want to vote for
a candidate in your country who supports a bunch of kids getting
murdered. in a different country. That is the effect. That is
what they think they're voting against, right? That is the effect
of voting u like for anybody who's supportive of Israel at this
point. For somebody who's supportive of funding to Israel, that
all of the funding, the the what do you call it? The um the defense
guarantee, right? The defense guarantee, all of the funding,
the qualitative military edge, all of this leads to the way Israel
acts in that area of the
So you American policy is directly leading to the destruction
of these people's lives. I think it's okay to oppose that. I
don't see why anybody would think something otherwise. I think
it's totally fine to say I oppose that categorically. I won't
vote for somebody who supports it. I don't I just I really I
struggled to come up with a way I could say that that's wrong.
>> Like he kind of the first things out of his mouth were
like ridiculous and they were attacks on Bill. Uh and it was
this like kind of uh it was just like garbage lefty nonsense.
And I also had a fight with him on the stage and condemned what
he was saying and also was like this guy's worthless uh as a
like I I don't I don't find him to be >> so make the argument
interesting as a thinker or and I get I get that he's got a big
audience but just because these guys have big audiences
doesn't mean they're all created equal. Again, I think this is
why I know you that the five month thing and right is always
right. And again, I I think that people in the commentary space
that want to criticize him should >> and and I and I understand
that right is always right. In my in my argument for engaging
with him last night, I just I said it was like even this week
he attacked Scott Weiner, state senator out of California, for
visiting Israel after October 7th. And >> so much so much
throat clearing. She's definitely going to pay attention to what
her argument is now. So much throat clearing.
Like I attacked him for saying this. I thought it was gross.
Oh, now she's going to listen to you. This guy, this guy totally
says he supports, you know, America did 911 or sorry, America
deserved 911. He still stands by that. Total lie, by the way.
Total lie. Well, sorry, total lie in that he thinks it was a
good idea to say that and he apologized for saying it the way
he did. The the point of that, by the way, is that America the
way America acts on the global stage leads to terrorist attacks.
you are doing something that incurs a response that that incurs
a debt you will see a response to this whether you like it or
not right which by the way if you don't think it's going to happen
now I I'm pretty scared about it
I'm pretty terrified about it that like this is a whole new thing
where you're destroying an entire country
where you are now having Shiites ethnically cleansed from southern
Lebanon right and further they're saying don't even take them
in in Beirut don't take them anywhere don't allow Don't allow
Shiites in your country. They're getting terms dictated to them
at this point. Guess what? Those Shiite Muslim Those Shiite Muslims
are the precise people. Nothing. I'm I'm not going to get into
it. We're going to chill on that for a second. I want to watch
this substance clip.
I'm going to watch this substance clip. Okay, let me see what
the substance clip
only talking about a country with 9 million people like Israel
and you don't spend very much time at all talking about
other much bigger countries that are doing, you know, sometimes
even worse things, then it starts to get a little Which one?
Which one? Which one? Which one's doing even worse things? Which
one? Which one's been doing even worse things for a longer period
of time? Hutch, which one? Which one? Which one? But the population
thing doesn't save you. The little population thing makes it
worse. That, oh, they've got such a little population. Why are
you going after them? They're just a small bean. HOW IS THE SMALL
BEAN DOING THIS MUCH EVIL? >> It's like, why is Israel
the only thing being talked about here? >> Dude, Israel's
literally ethnically just ethnically cleansed like a million
people in Lebanon. And people are like, it just seems weird that
you're talking about Israel right now. Like what's the what's
the halflife on Israel doing some sort of like nefarious evil
thing? How long do we have to or how long can we complain about
it? Like it just seems odd that you guys are focused on Israel
right now. They keep doing evil. Yeah, I >> only talking
>> this this penguin guy kind of spitting right here. Okay,
this penguin guy kind of spitting. Hold on. I need to refresh
this and retweet it and then we continue on with the stream.
Oh my god.
Oh my god. I'm going to retweet that. Let's go. All right, juice
that tweet, guys. Juice that tweet. >> Juice that substance
tweet. That's a good one. That's a good one.
Let's go.
>> I was like, that's a crazy argument for engaging with
him last night. I just I said it was like even this week he attacked
Scott Weiner, state senator out of California, for visiting Israel
after
>> Oh, sure. I if I was appealing to voters, I'd do the
same thing. I'm I'm talking about like the statements in a vacuum
that they're saying. That's all I'm talking about. The statements
in a vacuum. And I was like, that's a crazy thing to attack somebody
over. That's that's an insane thing to attack somebody over.
And that's >> Oh, somebody get me this tweet if you don't
mind. Please get me this tweet specifically. Could somebody get
me the Scott Weiner tweet cuz I think it's a tweet, right? I
believe what Hassan's criticizing there is that this guy was
trying to run as somebody who is anti-Israel.
I thought that was what it was. That like, hey, we're going to
hold Israel accountable. And it's like, dude, I don't think you're
going to hold Israel accountable. You're like, you're pretty
defensive of Israel. You you have like a connection to Israel.
It's like it's concerning. I'm trying to say that in a way that
doesn't just say you're aren't you. I don't know if he is, but
I don't think it's quite that
>> wrong. And and I find it repugnant actually. And but
we can disagree about that. Here's my problem though is why it
matters all in the in the context of
>> You're saying that these guys are being elevated by
the Stryand effect. And I I think that that is part of it. It
is true. And I think that again and I think that's why this is
counterproductive
to have this fight right now um for
pro-Israel Democrats or centrist Democrats or whatever any of
those groups because I think right now he's being elevated quite
a bit but I don't think that's what's elevating him. I I mean
I think that what is happening in the world is elevating him
in the moment. I'm >> dude she has to take another deep
breath. She's she literally they had to switch to his camera
cuz she needs to go get the paper bag. I think I think what's
elevating him is uh Israel doing evil. Israel keeps doing evil
over and over again. They're continuously doing evil. I think
that's what's actually elevating Hassan. >> And and I just
I'm sorry. This is like very uncomfortable for like defenders
of Israel to deal with. But like what happened was we were in
a world after October 7th with a lot of people that were too
soon for my taste out there attacking Israel for what they're
doing in Gaza and how they were prosecuting the war and they
were doing so in ways that that talked explicitly >> clearly
anti-semitic. >> Okay. Well, there that there are times
that they're clearly anti-semitic, but there are also times where
they were where they were talking about things
Dude, dude, this lady is this lady is the precise kind of person
that yesterday I was talking about when I said, "Just shut up.
This is not your time. Your time can come a different time. Right
now, you need to understand how bad you're making your own movement
look. You need to shut the up immediately. You are actually all
of your goals are going out the window because you can't shut
the up for two seconds and you need to you badly badly need to
like strategically that other people weren't talking about in
the news like like the amount of death and and destruction that
was happening to the Palestinians in Gaza. And they were talking
about that passionately
and and maybe they're passionately and earnestly anti-Semitic.
Okay. But they were talking about this topic passionately. Talking
about how Israel is a malign influence on the world. And that
>> hold on, hold on. I got to turn it up. I don't know
if I'm the only one who could hear it. Listen. >> Topic
passionately talking about how Israel is a malign influence on
the world. And >> you hear you hear her doing the same
thing again. You hear it in the background. Sorry. I I had to
turn it all the way up there. Okay. I don't I don't know if I
blew your eardrums out. I'm sorry, but you had to hear it. Okay.
they have too much and that they have too much influence in American
politics that we're giving them too much uh aid uh that that
Apac is too involved in these campaigns and if you came the security
guarantee provided by the United States along with the qualitative
military edge totally tilts the playing field in Israel's favor.
So even if these other countries wanted to try to militarily
intervene, the US sits there, right? The Israel is like this
little kid who's walking around and like flicking people on the
nose, okay, irritating all of them, doing this thing all over
the region. Sometimes I'm going to even say they're probably
hitting terrorists. They're probably like trying to actually
get rid of people who are a threat to them, right? But it's with
very little concern for the collateral damage. All right? Not
enough concern for the collateral damage. But they're they're
going around, they're flicking all these people in the nose and
and then all these people look to respond and they see the big
the big bad wolf behind Israel making it so they can't respond,
right?
So like even even things like the qualitary mil even things like
the qualitative military edge, even things like the security
guarantee, these things lead to Israel being being able to act
in a way that is like delitarious to not just Israel's interests
but also America's interests. >> Man, listen to my show
a year ago. Like anytime this topic come up, I was on the side
of I was on the opposite side. I was saying, "Guy, you're overstate.
It's kind of anti-Semitic how you're blaming Apac for everything.
You're overstating Apac's influence." And all of their crit critiques
of Israel. Israel has just done everything that they said. Like,
only anti-semmites say that we're killing children and and starving
people to death. Only anti-semmites say this. It comes out that
they're starving people to death and they're killing a bunch
of children. Um, why did you prove the anti-semmites right? I
don't get it. I thought it was like who did you have to prove
the anti-semit you know that makes it way harder for me to argue
for you right why'd you do that >> like Apac now is the
key player in Democratic primaries and enter nine primaries they
are the the group that is putting the most money in that's not
a conspiracy theory that's just what's happening I talked to
Democratic strategists they're like the the race is going to
be determined based on Apac's involvement like that just is what
it is right now and Israel did then continue to go way overboard
for in their prosecution of the war in Gaza. And then not to
mention what's happening in the West Bank with the settlements,
not to mention the fact that they're invading Lebanon right now.
And then we did get into a war with this. >> By the way,
this precise conversation, Tim is in a meta way engaging in the
exact same thing he's trying to he's advocating for others to
do, right? He's saying speak with clarity on the issue. Do not
couch it in like but you have to be careful about how you talk
about it. Do not couch it in anything. Just speak with clarity
on the issue. say what is happening. Do not lie. Do not sugarcoat.
And then eventually once people's fervors like come down, you
can have a different conversation with people. You could talk
about how like, hey, I think you know when when somebody said
this that ventured into anti-semitism and that's really concerning
to me, but you will never be able to have that conversation from
a place of like all within weeks of Lebanon, southern Lebanon
being ethnically cleansed, you'll never be able to have that
calm conversation with somebody where it's like, well, have you
thought about how the way you're talking about this is going
to lead to increased anti-semitism in the West? No. I'm thinking
about all those families that are displaced.
Okay. So, he's actually engaging. He's practicing what he's preaching
actively in the conversation which is always >> Israel
like that the secretary of state said we got into because Israel
was going to attack first if we didn't do it. So like all of
So sure there might have been some anti-semitic stuff mixed in
there and that's not good. I'm not okaying that. I'm not it's
bad. They should not do anti-semitic stuff. But like their general
critique of the lefty anti and right like anti-Israel
commentators
like has borne out in the real world. And so I don't I I don't
know what pro-Israel people expect like
unfortunately we have to deal with the fact and he's saying it
and it's it's just funny to listen to it because I I don't even
think necessarily like Hassan's anti-semitic. I actually don't
think Hassan's anti-Semitic at all but I do think like Fentes
is anti-semitic and he keeps saying like unfortunately we have
to deal with the fact that the anti-semites predicted Israel's
behavior perfectly. Unfortunately we have to contend with that
now. I didn't want that to be the case. I was arguing on the
opposite side. I just want you have to admit that they were 100%
correct in how they predicted Israel's behavior. And we have
to we have to reckon with that. And it's not even like a joke.
It sounds like a joke, but it's NOT A JOKE. YOU ACTUALLY do have
to reckon with that. You actually do have to figure out how to
talk about it now. Because for a whole bunch of time, the way
everybody got out of having these conversations, these tough
conversations about how Israel operated was you would go, "You're
an anti-semite for saying this." And then the conversation would
end. And that that trump card no longer exists. Trump killed
that trump card for you.
Global strat visualize. Please don't be Rabbi Schmoolie or that
other guy from from Spain.
>> Not so fast little bro. >> Oh true. It is >> little
bro. What are you going to do? >> It is like Jack's Jack
Jack Dory and his bodyguard. It is Listen.
It is. It is not so fast little bro. Not so fast.
>> It's it it be like that a little bit. Okay, it do be
like that a little bit. >> Uh there's been a huge sea change.
If you just look at the polls of voters, they're looking around,
they're like, I am unhappy with our rel with the extent of our
relationship militarily with this country. I'm unhappy with this
war. All of the establishment figures want to kind of tamp that
down, and there are these other voices out there that have been
speaking about it. Well, obviously, they're going to gain influence.
And shouldn't the shouldn't Democratic politicians talk to the
viewers of those shows? They're not all anti-semites. They're
just unhappy with how things are going in the world. >> I
think you can do it. So this what I don't like and I I don't
want to say that I think you're falling into a trap, but I do
think that there are ways. One of my biggest critique.
>> Uh yeah, I always thought the sharky girl. I always
thought Israel had the right to to retaliate to go back in and
try to kill Hamas. Honestly, if they end, it's still like an
incredible amount of destruction. But that was the point of the
conversation I was having back then. That's what really flipped
me and made me look more into the issue and take the other side
more seriously was I was pro-Israel. I said they had the right
to defend themselves. They had the right to go do operations
on the ground. I thought it would go disastrously. I thought
it would be like they would wreak havoc on the area. I basically
said Palestinians should get the [__] out of there.
I wouldn't trust Israel at all with some of the stuff they've
done. I wouldn't trust them at all to be like co to be what do
you call it? Like um concerned about killing civilians or anything,
right? And then they didn't
they they weren't concerned. They did everything I was concerned
they would do and they didn't stop at like, you know, 10 to1
kill ratio. They just kept going. They kept mowing through the
area until it was basically like a significant portion of it
was flattened or damaged,
right? And once that once that's the case, like I don't know
what to tell you. I I thought 10 to1 that's where you draw the
line. You go, okay, we have to pull back. But that was reached
very quickly and they did not do so. And they kept they kept
using all of the same arguments. Listen, it's a gen Hamas has
a genocidal ideology. They have to be eradicated entirely. Yeah.
Well, you're fighting an ideology now. That means you get to
kill infinite civilians.
That's a problem. That's a problem. And then it was a problem
>> of Democrats in the book. And the thing I am urging
them to do is to get out there on offense, to say what they believe.
They should passionately argue against this war if that is what
they believe. If it's not, that's different. But like they should
passionately argue about it so that people listen to them
>> and so they have credibility on this. That is that doesn't
require Hassan per
this idea that this well >> this is part of the problem.
Is Hakeim Jeff doing that? Is Chuck Schumer doing that? Are the
2028ers? Chuck Gavin Newsome came out there and was like, "Oh,
Israel is an aparttheid state." Then he apologized. >> ignore
but this is why
Hassan Per. They should ignore Hassan perg.
Ignore him.
and and condemn him. I think if I do not think it's hard if you
listen when we were anti-Trump, right? The reason that we were
anti-Trump is partly because he like loved to be in lock.
>> Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. We should IGNORE
HIM. AND YOU SHOULD DISAVOW. There's no way she just said that.
You should condemn. We should ignore them. And they should condemn.
That's not the same. >> Ignore them.
and and condemn him. I think if I do not think it's hard,
>> I swear every single person who isn't like this died
in the wool like absolute ideological Zionist, this is their
face every single time when they run into somebody from their
real life that they didn't think was like this ideologically
committed. And they're starting to see that ideological commitment
play itself out. This is the face every single time. He's just
like total totally baffled, total disbelief. He's like, "Dude,
I thought you were like a like
I thought we were totally on the same page." And I'm absolutely
finding out that we're not on the same page. We don't think the
same things at all. Right.
Like this is the face every single time. It It will never not
be funny. He He just looks totally baffled by this conversation
right now. He's experiencing [__] shock. If you listen
when we were anti-Trump, right, the reason that we were anti-Trump
is partly because he like loved to be in lock. >> Why did
he make an even worse face? Why did he do it even harder, dude?
He can't believe it. He But this is like what happens. This is
um this is what I felt like with Adam Sausnik. I'm like, wait,
Adam's like a totally disingenuous grifter. Why is he like why
is he totally leaving it all in the field for Israel right now?
Like I don't I don't this this is not
this is not like the way I viewed him at all. And suddenly out
of nowhere he is like absolutely
he's willing to tank his career to argue on behalf of Israel.
It's crazy. Yeah. This is my exact feeling when I watch Adam
do it the first time. >> Step with all the grossest people
uh who had gross opinions. It's like the very fine people on
both sides. It's the way he checks in with Tucker. And the right
would argue this. Why is JD Vance cozying up to them? Why do
we condemn them? We condemn JD Vance for cozying up to bad people
for electoral reasons. And that I think is the problem. That's
>> And here's the other thing about Hassan is when the
only thing you focus on is the what you say is anti-semitism.
And you say crazy things like you compare him to right-wingers,
to JD Vance refusing to disavow Nick Fentes, you compare him
to Nick Fuentes in general. When you do this smear,
you give the entire game away. You've given the entire game away
automatically,
right? It's over already.
You've done this smear. They're not even close to the same. And
there's only one reason you would do that smear
without checking in, right? There's only one reason. It's because
you want people to you want people to not have a correct idea
of how bad Hassan's anti-semitism could be, right? because you're
defending, you are really actually just ideologically committed
to this one issue, right? When there's all this stuff there,
there's a part of Tim's argument. When there's all this other
stuff there, like all of his commentary on China that you could
go after, that you could be upset about, and you pick the Israel
issue, the one where he actually looks good to a lot of people,
it gives the game away.
Game is given
>> You should cozy up.
>> Yeah, Shark Girly,
I I see what you're saying. I would love to have this conversation
on stream at some point, okay? That Hassan is illiberal. I want
you to try to lay this argument out that Hassan is illiberal.
I I think you should have to lay out why you think he is pushing
towards an illiberal America.
Not even not even just like, well, some deep-seated part of him
kind of likes China and kind of thinks Mao is cool. Cuz I don't
really think that's being a liberal. But I want you to like I
want people to unpack this and tell me what it means. When you
say Hassan is illiberal, what do you mean? This is where the
>> you're kind of mean so I don't want to. >> People
are attacking me. I just I think they're wrong. I'm not I'm not
arguing that they cozy up. I It's fine to go on a show and argue
to disagree with him. The what prompted all this was the idea
that John Oaf has to condemn Hassan
>> You know what's funny? Because Hassan [__]
complimented him. That's insane. You is what John Oaf should
say. John Oaf should say, you know what? I don't know what Hassan
Piker's whole
that is. >> I don't know who that is. Here's what my opinion
is. I'm against this war in Iran. I' I'm against this warrant.
I'm against this Trump administration that's killing people in
the streets and that's what I care about. You want me to talk
about some streamer eat that's what I think John was on your
side. I was on your side on that point. It was the rest of it.
It was last night. It was last night listening to it being that
the I do not think though for electoral reasons they need to
embrace Hassan. That is different. >> Did I say embrace?
I never said embrace. I said talk to his audience. talk to the
people that listen to him and Joe Rogan and Theo and Sneo, all
these anti-war people that Yeah, there are some anti-semites
there. I hear that. Guess what? Guess what? Anti-semites voted
for Barack Obama. Anti-semmites voted for George Bush. Anti
>> I I'll tell you the people who watch
>> unless you're talking to or about Hassan, they're never
checking out your show. You have nothing of value to say, right?
Like to somebody who believes what Hassan believes, this person
has nothing of value to say. So you could go like, "Well, you
should engage with the ideas or you should engage with they're
never going to find you." Tim is saying, "Go find them and go
agree with them on this and try to pull them to your ideas. Try
to go and say, "I actually agree with you on the Israel issue.
I'm just a little different on economics. Here's where I differ
on economics. We could have that debate, right? Don't go and
debate Hassan on Israel. Go and debate Hassan on China. Go and
debate Hassan on economics. go and debate Hassan on something
unrelated to Israel
because that's where you'll win people. Take his advant take
his advantage and strategically, this is just totally correct.
There's no possible way you could disagree with this. Take his
advantage which is he has he has uh what is it? Credibility on
the Israel issue, right? Take that advantage and turn it into
something positive for you. Drink his milkshake. Yes. Exactly.
And by the way, it's if you are somebody who believes what Hassan
believes, you're you're trying to push in the same direction
Hassan is. This lady is totally helping you.
Tim is arguing that, hey, you should try to connect to people
who found Hassan over this issue and show empathy on that issue
and try to win them over to your side, which is, by the way,
and I hope you understand, it can't be win them over to my side
so I can support more funding for Israel. That can't be it. That's
why when when Hassan calls that guy out who is like an ideological
Zionist, somebody who's going to octo going to Israel right after
October 7th, when he says, "I don't find you credible on the
idea that you're going to be Israel skeptic."
That is a fair thing to say.
when people are this concerned about the issue, that is a totally
fair thing to say. You have to live with that. >> Like
ant gay haters, ant homophobes, >> you don't have to court
them. >> Well, no, but you have to have a message. Yeah.
the voters. You have to have a message for the people that listen
to the show >> because of the anti-semitism. Like >> you
have a message for people that listen to the show. It's like,
oh, let's make sure that the >> he's already argued he
doesn't think the all of the audiences are anti-semitic.
He just argued that, right? He just said >> the people
in MLAN, Virginia with the that go to the parties in DC are mad.
It's like, who cares what those people think? Talk to the real
Americans that are flocking to these shows that are upset about
what is happening in the world. Have a message for them. Talk
to them. go on go on the platforms to talk to them and if then
the host says anti-semitic stuff say no I don't believe that
I don't believe the were behind Charlie Kirk's mortar I don't
believe the control the weather I don't believe that the like
there's a lot of okay whatever I don't believe that we deserve
911 >> hold on hold on hold on I don't believe that the
control the weather I don't believe the behind Charlie Kirk's
murder that is easy thank you Tim >> say all that on those
platforms but also say to people that you know what I'm mad about
I'm not mad about some streamer and something he said three years
ago like what I'm mad about is the this war that we're in right
now. And I think that there are a lot of people out there that
feel like the Democratic leaders are totally out of touch. >> Dude,
you want to know what's actually crazy?
It's the crazy making of Tim Miller over this position. This
is the objectively correct position to have in every possible
way.
And it's crazy. It's insane
that Tim Miller is being crazy made over this position. It's
like so obviously
with their anger right now and and I think that this is just
exa like this kind of fight just exacerbates that. >> I
agree with that that particular point about it exacerbating it.
And so I again I think that we should separate the idea of like
Democrats should be going hard against this war. They do need
to be more aggressive. They do need to speak to a wider audience.
I do not think they need to do that with Aan [__]
with and I do not think they and I think they should be very
clear to separate from the anti-semmites as >> Oh, I might
Yeah, hold on. Yeah, if if Tim talks to Destiny over this content,
that's something that like intersects with three different issues
that I actually follow. So, unfortunately, we will be covering
that if Tim does talk to him. Okay. Like, I'm good with that.
they do it because otherwise what you are doing is jinning up
anti-semitism
and I understand and last night I was >> here's the part
of the problem can I before we're going to do this I'm just going
to say it I am don't support anti-mitism I think there's a lot
of anti-semitism out there I think that a lot of the people who
are pro-Israel and pro this war weaponize this though and
he's taking steps that I would never expect him to take yes
that is true now that in and of itself will be called anti-semitic
but yes that is absolutely true, Tim. Thank you for pointing
it out. That's the problem.
That is the problem. That is a major >> It's like, well,
it's too anti-semitic. Like, like you, if I would have said a
month ago that Israel is >> what? Like, listen, this is
what you're saying. What if I said, okay,
it's I'm trying to find a good example. I won't have the analogy
just right. It's like, what if I said I don't care about these
kids getting killed over here because I think you're like being
a little rude to me right now.
Listen, I understand some kids are dying over there, but you're
being a little rude to me right now, right? It's like you're
you're taking a way less pressing, way less
like um a way less pressing, way less time-sensitive concern
and you're using that to assuage people to to get people to not
talk about something, right? It is not. Anti-semitism is a concern,
but it is not something that is blowing up in the United States
to the degree that Gaz and children's heads are exploding. Okay?
And until we get to some parody there, please don't bring up
anti-semitism when I say Israel is doing war crimes. Please don't
bring up anti-semitism when I point out that Israel's ethnically
cleansed southern Lebanon. Please don't bring up anti-semitism
when I say that Israel caused a humanitarian crisis in Thran
has probably caused an untold number of cancers. Okay? Don't
bring up anti-semitism. Don't say anti-semitism.
Stop. Stop talking about anti-semitism
until the the parody is reached. All right. Thank you. >> Like
like you if I would have said a month ago that that Israel is
is is weaponizing social media to try to brainwash people. You
would have said that was anti-semitic. A lot of big Israel defenders
would have said that was anti-semitic. Well then BB went out
>> don't don't don't point out BB saying they need to take
over Tik Tok and then Larry Ellison getting a bit bitten. DON'T
POINT THAT OUT TO TIM. >> He wants to do that with Tik
Tok. He sees Tik Tok as a weapon. Okay. If you would have said
that Israel that we're >> quoting BB that Yahoo is one
of the most anti-semitic things you could do, Tim, what are you
doing? No. >> That Israel is going to drag America into
a war that has we have nothing to do with um based on their influence
over >> Wait, hold on. Sorry. I am I'm pausing a lot. That's
my bad. I'll roll it back here just a little bit so we don't
miss any context because Missy wanted to ask why not point that
out. I'm joking. I'm joking about how people are like like she's
gonna be upset about that that he's saying something about controlling
media. She's gonna get very upset about that. And if you haven't
been following Missy, she's been very upset this entire >> If
I would have said a month ago that Israel is is is weaponizing
social media to try to brainwash people, you would have said
that was anti-semitic. A lot of big Israel defenders would have
said that was anti-semitic. Well, then BB went out and said that
he wants to do that with Tik Tok. He sees Tik Tok as a weapon.
Okay. If you would have said that Israel that that Israel is
going to drag America into a war that has we have nothing to
do with um based on their influence over our political leaders
two months ago people would have said that's an anti-semitic
thing to say and now we're doing that and so I'm with you. >> Oh
god is she going to blow him up for that? Now we're doing that.
Uhoh. >> I'm with you. I I'm not for antism that what happened
in in Michigan is a tragedy. People should be cleareyed. but
also this notion that like that that there's a lot of folks out
there that are trying to police the rhetoric around this because
they don't want Israel to be criticized in the full full view
of their actions and and there's a lot of criticism of Israel
that is merited right now and I just think that this again it
goes back to who you empowering think that if you try to like
do like if on one side Israel is starting a war in Iran and and
getting us into this quagmire and hurting people's lives and
then on the other side you people that are saying things about
Israel and like you're out there and you're like I don't like
the way that you're talking and that's the thing that you're
very passionate about and then you're not that passionate you're
like well I don't I don't know you know we have to BB's a partner
we've got to work with them we'll see you know what I mean like
there's a disconnect
with people and I think again you're empowering the actual anti-semmites
I think you're empowering the actual anti-semites by not being
just cleareyed about the real threat here
you can tell she's having a hard time not speaking right Now,
it's very, very, very funny. >> How is this different?
This is the one of the sort of the main thing, and this is this
is tough, but I'm going to put it out there. How is it different?
>> Our objection to Trump.
>> When he showed up, like, and this is where I don't when
people were like, "It's locker room talk." I was like, "You locker
room talk." No, it's not. Like, the way they tried to downplay
things like we stood against >> it was objectively talk.
You could say it's indicative of some mindset, but it's objectively
talk. This is everybody going, they're going to kill a bunch
of people, a bunch of civilians in Gaza. They're going to ethnically
cleanse the people from Gaza. They're not going to let them go
back. They're going to totally turn that place into rubble. And
everybody went, that's like crazy. No, they're the most moral
army in the world, right?
And then the people who said the first thing were totally correct,
totally vindicated.
There's not. This is like if this is like you're arguing basically
that Trump said that Trump said some crazy and you're just like
it's just locker room talk and then he went and like woman live
on TV and you're like well
I mean come on it's pretty anti-Trump it's pretty up and anti-Republican
for you to like keep pointing this out and keep talking about
it. It's not you you can't do this man. Trump and look everybody
else on the right I don't take >> all right not a perfect
analogy
like they're not in a position uh to levy this because what they
did is say you know what we need Nick went as his audience we
need Tucker's audience uh we need to all get on board with Trump
despite the horrific things he's saying because he's right about
XYZ yeah right or and and the populist rage that people had well
Trump is going to embody that and we said no we stand against
random rage from people or rage from people even about things
that maybe there were right to be mad about income inequality,
foreign stupid foreign wars, right? Like Trump had messages that
resonated with people and we were like, "No, we stand against
that because this guy is a foul person who is going to do tremendous
damage to America. We were right about that. Why
>> why isn't why I
maintain that against people like >> Hassan? One, Hassan's
not running for president. If he ends, I I change my views. That
would be one. Number two, Trump was running for president. Number
two is like again that's not really the apt comparison, right?
Like the apt comparison is
should Republican
have gone to megaurches
to talk to people that have, you know, influential pastors that
have terrible views about
Maybe they shouldn't have. I don't know. You know what I mean?
But like, don't you have to communicate? >> They definitely
did do that. >> Yeah, they definitely did do that. But
like don't you have to communicate to the religious voters on
the I mean some of this is not like apt because I think that
like the vulk that listen to Hassan that like are mad about Israel
like have a point. Um and like the vulk on the right that are
like mad about mass immigration coming into the country like
I don't think really have a point. But like that >> that's
kind of more the comparison but Han's still like way better.
Hassan's Han's viewers way better. That's like kind of the comparison
like in just as a strategic matter in retrospect like obviously
the establishment Republicans should have listened more to their
base to avoid having them being overthrown by by Trump. That's
maybe more of the apt comparison with Assan. But I just again
this is like I think this is this is why I think this is this
is like why I think this is funny. Like my issue with the Democrats
running for office that are that are in office and are in power
is that they're not criticizing our foreign policy enough. Like
that's my criticism that they're not passionate enough. I don't
think there's any risk right now that there's like some emerging
I guess Zoran I guess example he's got a moderated in New York
and that's kind of avoided foreign policy issues like maybe Zoran
was running for Senate it would have been different but like
who is the who do you want me to condemn? Like who is the person
in the Democratic party that h like
doesn't she know that Hassan's audience is largely just young
dumb people? Why is she villainizing them? She's villainizing
them because she has probably drank the Kool-Aid because she
is an ideological Zionist. She's incredibly committed and she's
probably drank the Kool-Aid to some extent. She might not really
be lying when she says Hassan is just like Nick Fentes. She might
genuinely believe that. That's totally incorrect, but she might
genuinely believe that because she's drank the Kool-Aid, right?
So, she's demonizing the viewers because she thinks there's a
lot of overlap in the viewers when there isn't. Right.
>> Yep. like is advancing these real anti-semitic views
like Talib sometimes in the house. I'm happy to condemn her when
she talks every once in a while. Yeah, sure. Okay. But like,
all right, these are couple like two random members of the house.
So, like, sure, I'll condemn them. But like the the power structures
in the Democratic party,
it's nothing this is nothing like Trump. This is not apt at all.
This is not like, oh, you left the party over Trump. I was like,
well, Trump took over the whole party. I fought him.
>> Bran says she watches the Bulwark and Hassan. This lady
doesn't know her own audience. oof from within the party and
then he took it over and then I fought him from within the party
and then eventually everybody I lost the fight and I left the
party like that's what >> like this this fight isn't even
happening in the Democratic party yet like the Democratic party
leadership is in my view >> like not radical enough
I don't like that so I don't think that this I don't this comparison
does nothing for me >> okay well let me just try one more
time my objection in large part with Trump was that he tried
to work on people's worst impulses, right? He appealed to the
racism, the xenophobia,
the hatred.
>> Oh, this is going to be rough. Cuz that's probably not
I don't even think Hassan's most deranged haters really think
that's what Hassan doesn't appeal to the worst impulses. He appeals
to good impulses that are easily hijacked. Right? That would
be the criticism of Hassan. He appeals to people's empathy. He
appeals to people's like want to help other people. He appeals
to things that are ruinous if not controlled. Trump sort of maybe
that's the the way you talk about it, but it's not the worst
impulses. It's impulses that like, hey, you need to make sure
that you are like you've got your life vest on before you start
helping somebody who's drowning, right? Like it's more of that's
the risk of Hassan people of like Hassan's way of talking is
he's trying to tap into good impulses people have that are a
little easier to tap into than just the well they're easier to
tap into than just like some, you know, convincing people. Han,
sorry, Trump taps into impulses that are similar, but they are
negative. They are the like xenophobia, they are like racism,
that that kind of thing. That's what he taps into. >> The
bad stuff. And I don't want Democrats to go down that road. I
think it is very important when you fight Trump, when you look
into the abyss, the abyss looks back at you. And Democrats should
avoid the mistakes that I think the Republicans made that made
us leave, which was embracing intolerable people. and your that
point that you're making
>> uh Puffshake, thank you for the gifted sub. And Lily
Luna 8527, thank you for the two gifted. And Myra, thank you
for the five gifted. That's eight subs. That's two more hours
on the stream. Let's go, guys. Let's go. 2 hours 1345. Private
Huff, thank you for a gifted sub there as well. Appreciate it.
Appreciate
Let's Let's keep it running. Let's keep this train going. All
right. Did I get everybody? I got everybody. I almost missed
Private Huff, but thank you very much, Private Huff, for the
gifted sub. Let's continue. >> A fair one. It is fair to
say >> or sorry, I should back it up just to get the full
context here. >> Should avoid the mistakes that I think
the Republicans made that made us leave, which was embracing
intolerable people. And you're that point that you're making
about Trump is a fair one. It is fair to say that Hassan is just
like a streamer. He's not the guy running for president. But
I do think the elements of your argument which is that Hassan
is representing an angry base and the base needs to be listened
to. That's what happened with Republicans. They're like Trump
represents an angry base and the base needs to be listened to.
>> Yeah. But I think >> well the base did need to
be listened to for the angry Republicans. It didn't need to be
listened to by somebody who is going to constantly not listen
to them. Just tap into the rage they had and then totally not
care about solving any of their issues. Right? like when people
voted for Trump the first time, it's people who had lost their
jobs due to like offshoring in
uh in the rust belt. Okay, guess what? That problem of people
feeling disaffected because they've lost their jobs, they don't
have prospects, it turns out if you'd solved that problem, if
you'd figured out some way to start solving that problem to start
making people feel better about that, that would have been really
good cuz a ton more people are going to be suffering with that
over the next 5 or 10 years, right? That is a problem that does
need to be addressed. Trump has totally failed to address it.
So, Democrats have a lane here. Democrats didn't have a lane
in 2016. Everybody was painting them as the party of free trade
agreements that led to all the offshoring of jobs, that led to
the offshoring of manufacturing, hollowed it out entirely, right?
And they didn't have a leg to stand on. Now, they have a leg
to stand on because Trump has totally failed to address any of
their core concerns.
So, it doesn't mean you have to appeal to those voters or you
have to you have to appeal to their rage. You don't have to appeal
to their worst impulses. You just have to try to solve the issues
that are making them anxious, making them upset. Otherwise, what
are you arguing for? Politics where you don't even take into
account what the voter base wants. Well, that sounds stupid.
The base is bright. This in this case, again, I I just I think
that what is Eli in this conversation is again
>> Tim keeps saying this and she doesn't know what to say
in response to it. Yeah. Yeah. But they were like wrong. Like
I already said that if you didn't hear me the first time the
the xenophobic voters in the Republican base who were appealed
to they were wrong and Hassan's base is right. Israel did go
too far. It's correct to be upset about this actions of Israel.
And I just I when I look at this again I do not condone Hassan's
anti-semitic comments. I specifically criticized his tweet this
week about Scott Weiner. So like I think that it's bad. But if
I if I am worried about anti-semitism in this country and like
that is my top worry and if you're and and that is what a lot
of these groups that are trying to make Hassan an issue about
if that is my top worry and
my main focus is on condemning Hassan [__] I I I
think that you've lost your mind. I think if that I I think that
that is just a totally counterproductive thing to do. I think
that a by doing that you're empowering him and empowering the
views you don't like. And I think that the biggest problem with
anti-semitism in this country right now is that the United States
is engaged in a war and everyone who just has eyes is looking
at this war and being like, I don't understand why we're in.
>> There's no way he just said that. Sorry, I looked away
for two seconds. I got to back it up. That's my bad. That's my
>> If that is my top worry and
my main focus is on condemning Hassan [__] I I I
think that you've lost your mind. I think if that if I >> Hey,
you're crazy. You're You're crazy, lady. Hey, you you we're having
this conversation. You're crazy. >> I think that that is
just a totally
>> dude. Just deep breaths the whole time. It's so funny,
man. I got to listen to it again. >> I think that you've
lost your mind. I think that I I think that that is just a totally
counterproductive thing to do. I think that a by doing that you're
empowering him and empowering the views you don't like. And I
think that the biggest problem with anti-semitism in this country
right now is that the United States is engaged in a war and everyone
who just has eyes is looking at this war and being like, I don't
understand why we're in it. And the most reasonable explanation
I can think of is that Israel wants us to be in it because this
is an acute issue for Israel. And I think that that's going to
create a lot of people that are very upset at Israel. And and
and
by nature, unfortunately,
what is going to result from that is is is increased anti-semitism.
And if I was somebody who's worried about anti-semitism in this
country and and if I was a Democratic party leader, I think that
both the right thing to do and the strategic thing to do would
be to be 100x louder in criticism of BB than I am in criticism
of Hassan Ber. >> I So
if you if you want me to denounce Hamas, then you MUST DENOUNCE
ISRAEL A THOUSAND TIMES. and and on this >> I think that
both the right thing to do and the strategic thing to do would
be to be a hundredx louder in criticism of BB than I am in criticism
of Hassan Ber. >> So and and on this point I'll just say
I think I am in agreement that strategically what does this is
something people fall into and I think Democrats do as well where
they focus too much on sort of trying to critique the thing they
think is bad instead of saying the thing they think is right.
And so what I would like for Democrats to do is like go go swing
hard on how you feel about
this. The way that Trump got us into this war, the fact that
he has not he didn't even ask Congress that he the way that Trump
got us into this war by totally deferring to BB Netanyahu and
intelligence for BB Netanyahu, right? That he was totally fooled
into this war by a very specific actor, the prime minister of
Israel.
kind of like Israel dragged us into this war, right? Say you
gota see you're not speaking with this is what I'm talking about.
You have no credibility at all if you cannot say the thing. No
way.
He's like, "Dude, we're we're so we're so What is happening?
What is happening? What is occurring?
What? Dude, I got to watch the way that Trump got us into this
war. The fact that he is not he didn't even ask Congress that
he >> dude this guy's got the worst poker face I've ever
seen in my entire life. I want You got one You got one game of
poker for your life. Okay, this is the guy you want on the other
side of the table. Th this guy with this total lack of poker
face. Okay, he can't even hide how he's feeling, how weird this
is right now. What he's what he's watching unfold. He's like
totally put off by it. It's awesome. He has done nothing for
the to ask the American people or make a case to the American
people. Like everything about this from top to bottom has been
an insane adventure. It's the exact opposite of what he ran on.
Oil prices are now high. There's a million things to criticize.
Go. >> Do you notice? Hold on. I did Did she say a single
thing about Israel there? Did she say one single thing about
Israel at all? Or did she There's no way she whiffed on every
single issue. on every single problem you could have with Israel
over this. I'm I'm listening to it again. I'm grabbing my phone
real quick. Give me two seconds. >> Go
swing hard on how you feel about
this. The way that Trump got us into this war. The fact that
he has not he didn't even ask Congress that he has done nothing
for the to ask the American people or make a case to the American
people. Like everything about this from top to bottom has been
an insane adventure. It's the exact opposite of what he ran on.
Oil prices are now high. There's a million things to criticize.
go hard. Go focus on that.
I don't think though I think it is a mistake. I think that it
is
a mistake to make it about Hassan [__] Um I >> So
just nothing. Just literally nothing. No nothing at all. I I
thought she was going to say I I think it's a mistake to make
it about Israel, but then she said Hassan [__] which
she's doing, by the way. This is literally what it was about.
So she Yeah. just seated the entire argument to Tim, I guess.
I don't >> I do think you have to drown out the anti-semites
and make a good clear uh case that is steeped in the things that
are right. Um and I do not
it's correct. It is correct to point out that Israel dragged
America into this war deceptively. Very deceptively. It was predicated
on a couple of things. One of the deceptions is that BB presented
to Trump that they could cause an uprising in Iran. that has
not come close to materializing. That is a deception. Trump's
own intelligence said, "No, there's no chance that's happening."
Trump went with Israel's intelligence instead. Israel pulled
America into this war based on lies, based on deceptions, based
on misunderstandings at best. Okay? And if you refuse to talk
about that, how they have how they're perfectly comfortable doing
that, presenting intelligence that is possibly outdated, that
conflicts totally with what America knows, right? that they're
totally comfortable doing that and putting American interests
at risk, putting American lives at risk, putting the American
economy at risk. They're totally comfortable doing that for their
own interests. If you refuse to point that out in this instance,
you are obviously going to allow the same things that have been
happening to continue happening. By the way, this is not even
remotely getting into the ethnic cleansing in Lebanon, what's
happening in Gaza, right? It's not even starting on that. It's
just talking about the war. And so she is that true? That is
true. Yes, we've read the article on stream that the MSAD leader
went out in the Israeli papers and said I told BB that we could
cause an uprising and I failed. We couldn't do it. When I read
that, I go, "Oh, BB knows that he's li he's lied. He's been caught
lying and now he has to come up with some convenient excuse for
why that lie was actually what he told and and truly believed
as well." That is how I interpret that article. Okay. Do >> not
think you need to. My last word is I do not think you need to
embrace uh people like Assad and I think it's fine to condemn
him the argument and >> condemn him and then go make your
own case but I don't I don't want us to. One of the things, this
is a sh note to bull work listeners, which is something that
is happening that bugs me is when people are like, "The bull
work is embracing Hassan." And I'm like, "Guys, I get it that
Tim's got the big big microphone, but like one man's opinion,
Um,
he's just saying don't criticize Hassan over Israel." And you're
not willing to say that. Although you said it's weird to make
it about Hassan. Just don't criticize Hassan over Israel. He's
correct on it. He's correct on it. Stop getting mad about it.
Do something else. >> Okay. There's many of us. We have
a big >> Oh, people are saying she hasn't listened to a
single word. No, she's listened. She just doesn't like that she
wasn't able to convince him. She's listened. She understands.
That's why she's talking around the issue in such a very specific
way. She's trying to get to like Tim saying, "Well, yeah, I guess
we kind of agree then." But without without actually saying the
thing. And Tim's noticed it. And that's why Tim's making the
faces he's making the whole time, right?
because
she doesn't want to admit that he's correct on this issue. She
doesn't want to admit that Hassan's correct on Israel right now.
She doesn't want to admit that.
And unfortunately, if you can't if you can never take your medicine,
it's like it's like a global case of Adam Sausnik, okay? Every
every problem we saw with Adam Sausnik on the PBD podcast where
he can't admit he up, he can't admit he's wrong, right? It is
a globalized case of that same thing. >> Big array of opinions.
we argue about them with each other. That's what the bull work
is about. Um, and so if you want honest conversations about tough
topics, like that's what we're going to do here. And that the
Twitter discourse does a real disservice to this >> I hear
you on that. And I and this is why it was funny. Actually, this
is just a comment. We can go meta since uh we've we've uh I think
expressed
views. The meta uh comment I think is funny about this is last
night after I did the stream I was I was like I did a you should
not do this. You should not do this is a bad thing to do as an
influencer commentator whatever and I don't I don't I try not
to do this that often but I was just >> you read the comments.
>> Yeah. No I no I tried to read the comments of the Bullwork
Plus members join Bullwork Plus now because you're part of our
community. I do want to hear their comments. No I searched Twitter
and Reddit >> like for like whether anybody was talking
about it or linking about it. like I searched for like myself
and Assan or whatever our names and it was like pretty funny
actually was that there are like anti-Hassan
>> clip accounts that
you can't make it up. You can't make it up. You can't make it
up. It's awesome. >> I clipped two of the things that I
said criticizing him and like was like Tim Miller goes after
Assan and then there were like anti, you know, because they're
trying to like make him a bad guy. their lefty anti-hassan, you
know, accounts and then they're like, yeah, then they're like
the pro the anti-bull >> They're like trying to make him
a bad guy. He is a bad guy. He is a bad guy. He is what do you
mean make him a bad he is a bad guy. >> He's a pro-Israel,
you know, whatever. Right-wing accounts like they had clipped
the ones where, you know, I was I was explaining why I don't
think the Democrats should distance from him being like the bull
work has gone full on. It's like this is just like the nature
of the discourse and I like and I do and we started this here
when I was like saying that there are like five subtopics here
like and and so anyway my closing point is for anyone that wants
to clip this like I do not like his politics and I disagree with
him and I think that we'll continue to fight over it. I think
the question then is okay how do you engage with that in a way
that's healthy and is it a is it in a way that's like burn the
witch is it a way that's ignore is it a way that's engage is
it somewhere in between all those things and I think that is
where the question is and my view is I think the most important
>> hold on oh this guy is smart I do like that this guy's
able to identify that like he's identified multiple times that
when you basically I understand this guy's job is to stream for
60 hours a week basically right I know that maybe not 60, maybe
45 to 50 hours a week. That's this guy's job. He's going to stream
that much. And Tim's thinking about that. He's like, "Well, if
if I stream that much for like 10 years, what would I say? Like,
what would I say if you recorded me all day every day for that
long?" And he's like, "Well, you could give me like this top
10." And like that top 10, while bad, it's like, "Dude, almost
anybody would have a really bad top 10." No,
almost anybody would have a really bad top 10. So if you could
only show me those comments, you're not showing me like the broad
base of what he talks about. Well, I've seen some of those viewers.
Some of those viewers watch us. And I don't think those people
are
So like you'd have to show me more than just one or two like
clips or comments because that's not enough.
I appreciate that from Tim. Smart guy. part about this to is
is like how do you talk to if you're the Democrats to the people
that listen to and trust him and how do you build trust and gain
trust with them without
looking into the best and having the best look back into you
right without becoming him without doing without you yourself
advancing.
>> Yeah. And here's the thing and I think this is the best
part is basically nobody has even tried to be like essentially
a neoliberal that's anti-Israel.
That's that's got to be electoral napalm. No, if everything these
people believe is true, shouldn't it be so easy to be the neoliberal
who just goes actually Israel sucks and then you're the you're
the moderate person who can make the moral decision on Israel
alone. Don't you just win? Yeah, neoliberal. I know people just
like I think it's it's like a this the associations are so strong.
Neoliberal to everybody means you're automatically like hyper
Zionist, right? And likewise, if you are anti-ionist, it means
to a bunch of people that you're automatically a communist. That
needs to be shattered. That needs to be shattered and done away
with. Okay? You will never achieve like Palestinian sovereignty.
You will never achieve better lives for the people in the Middle
East who are the victims of Israel if you constantly attach these
things. I said, neolib, I don't care to hold to that. I'm just
saying like a moderate a moderate liberal person who just like
likes capitalism has mostly standard bog bog standard center
you know center center left positions and but they have one outlier
position and that's I'm anti-Israel
that's all you need that's all you need that should be electoral
napal man
but nobody's doing it which is so concerning it's so weird that
there seems to be this like concerted effort to make it so that
as soon as you're anti-Israel you're either an anti-semite or
a communist
and it shouldn't have a connection. There shouldn't be a connection
there.
>> Views that that are wrong or hateful or whatever, but
like how can you engage them without doing that? That's what
I think that should be done. Um, and I think that was kind of
the crux of the the different differing views. So, do you have
a final comment or should we let it go? >> Uh, I think
we can let it I think we can leave it there. I just uh >> this
is like your sub secret pod for people who don't get the secret
pod. Sarah and JL are it's like the bull work has one voice.
Sir and Jay literally have an argument pot every week and it's
like the only thing we put behind the payw wall basically. Um,
as far as >> only half of it. >> Some people have
kids and it might not be the best time for the Glorious Revolution.
I don't even think that like like Hassan does all the aesthetics.
Hassan clearly loves the revolutionary aesthetic. Okay. Clearly
loves that. I don't know that he sincerely thinks that revolution
is like super important right now. That he sees it as revolution.
I don't know cuz I don't watch him enough to say. I get I get
the I just feel like, you know, it's probably not a revolutionary
time yet. It's getting closer and probably it will get there
eventually once we have enough people displaced from work, but
I don't know if it's there yet. Okay, but this is totally true,
Admiral Zuko, that basically you got to get people to wherever
they're going gradually. If you want to use the electoral system,
right? If you're not looking for an actual revolution, you're
just looking to use the electoral system. You have to move people
gradually. And
that's what some people should be looking to do.
Yeah. So, people can go check that out. Become a blog post member
on Substack or YouTube to get the secret pod if you enjoyed arguing
podcast because Sarah and JBL do this every week. I was happy
that I got to have a bonus argument. So, I appreciate you. I
love you and we'll see you soon. All right. >> Back at
you. Bye, guys. >> Bye, everybody.
>> Wow. What a cool What a cool little
video right there. That was very cool.